I'll buy your drink
Yeah you look so fly
Yeah how about a drink
Yeah you look so real
Yeah yeah
I saw you from across the room
That you came alone, I'll buy you a drink
Yeah yeah I'm real nola
No lie, 無論如何
Don't lie, I pay your flight
You fly, I say you fly
I say who's so bad
So bad
I want a shit
No lie
I say you're a fire
Yeah yeah
Oh yeah
These niggas ain't real
These niggas ain't got nothing real
oh yeah
j'me fais cesser jfais un room service
jt'ai vu a travers la room there bitch
reviens m'voir fait ton possible gros bras
toutes les positions sont possibles
donne moi du love que jdéverse ma haine
des love que j'aille sur la chaînet'a mes fans rêve la mienne sur la chèquel'or a français cela vaut la schnickjeuje laisserai même pas aller chez la sienneje laisserai même pas aller chez la sienne我老师,我老师,你去看我了你会想着我一样的我决定了,你自己在冰箱上我老师,我老师,你去看我了你不想着看我我还没放弄了一样的
我可以带你去看我了
你会发生的尸体
在哪里的路上
你不在那里面
我会让你描述
我像是一样的尸体
我会在一样的尸体
我会给你带我
我会给你带我一样的帖子
我一样的玩家
911 奴隷暴 奴隷暴 奴隷暴
Nouche on va
How about that shit
No lie
I say you're fine
Yeah yeah
How about that dream
Dola, everybody drink
Yola